bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous quels sont les remontées qu'on vous
fait du terrain de quoi souffre
précisément les commerçants que vous
distille ce qu'ils nous disent c'est
surtout les commerçants dans
l'équipement de la personne parce que
les commerçants concernant l'équipement
de des maisons se sont plutôt mieux tiré
à mieux me tue mieux tiré parce qu'ils
ont fait du clic et une collègue
ils ont mis six soumis du chiffre
d'affaires également libres et ont donc
aujourd'hui c'est surtout les
commerçants de l'équipement de la
personne le textile habillement la
chaussure et qui ont de gros stocks
également sur la fin d'année qui va
falloir payer alors que au mois de
novembre malheureusement nous n'aurons
pas pu ouvrir et le mois de décembre
s'il a été bon n'a pas pu compenser
cette perte de chiffre d'affaires et
donc pour certains d'entre eux pour
certains d'entre eux ils se posent la
question pour cent à peu près est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir continuer leurs
activités donc aujourd'hui il ya une
crainte pour ces commerçants et on
imagine que l'annoncé hier du couvre-feu
qui pourrait donc être avancé de deux
heures dès 18 heures dans certaines
régions c'est un nouveau coup dur aussi
pour eux alors heureusement c'est si je
vous dirai pas c'est pas dans tous les
départements
et effectivement dans ces départements
le fait d'avoir ces le le couvre-feu
daerden horaires où on fait du chiffre
d'affaires n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
mais c'est que ce qui est important
c'est que pour nous et c'est ce qu'on a
demandé sa légitime notre demande de
pouvoir ouvrir tous les dimanches du
mois de janvier
parce que c'est les dimanches sont des
chiffres d'affaires généralement assez
important et puis ça permettrait de
façon sanitaire également de mieux
fluidifier les flux saisir les a
partagées entre le samedi et le dimanche
est-ce qu'on a une idée aujourd'hui du
nombre du pourcentage de commerce qui
pourraient faire faillite ou qui ont
déjà fait faillite
alors on est bien sur les commerces de
l'équipement de la personne âgée
comme je le disais au départ c'est pas
l'ensemble des commerces et une partie
des commerces dits non essentiels dont
les avais mal nommé non essentiels c'est
surtout l'habillement et c'est surtout
la chaussure on quand on avait fait une
enquête en début d'année est on
aujourd'hui on peut penser que 20 % sont
en grande difficulté si vous voulez
quels sont les moyens qui sont mis en
oeuvre aujourd'hui pour venir en aide à
ces commerçants à ce que c'est suffisant
aussi selon vous la première des choses
pour leur venir en aide
c'est leur laisser faire leur métier de
pouvoir commercer avec le virus
d'autant que les protocoles que
sanitaires ont trait était très bien
appliqué il n'y a pas eu de clusters
dans le commerce et la meilleure façon
pour eux de pouvoir payer factures c'est
de faire du chiffre d'affaires et c'est
pour ça que on était très content des
centres de pouvoir ouvrir tous les
dimanches et qu'on souhaiterait de façon
exceptionnelle la voix également sur le
mois de janvier et qu'on puisse avoir
des autorisations par mode dérogatoire
c'est à dire qu'on n'oblige pas chaque
commerçant à faire une demande mais
qu'on puisse le faire pour eux de façon
collective
alors j'ai évoqué cette cellule d écoute
de bercy qui reçoit de plus en plus
d'appels très concrètement comment se
déroule l'accompagnement d'une personne
d'un commerçant qui entrent en contact
avec cette cellule
vous avez deux systèmes à vous avez le
système effectivement qui est national
dont vous parlez puis vous avez
également des chambres de commerce au
niveau territorial où il ya un peu plus
de proximité
nous avons des soucis de lison de
moments de ce moment là alors nous avons
malheureusement un souci où on va
revenir un instant si vous le voulez
bien sûr cette cellule d'écouté vous
nous expliquer l instant qu elle
fonctionne sous deux axes 2 il ya non il
ya deux systèmes bien les chambres de
commerce qui ont mis eux mêmes s'ils
voulaient un accueil pour des artisans
des commerçants qui sont en difficulté
et puis il ya le gère ce système
national de tes deux numéros verts qui
ait été mis en place de façon nationale
dans ce long serpent ces commerçants et
oui clairement c'est un vrai soutien
parce qu'on les met directement en lice
ont pris en charge directement par des
spécialistes des psychologues et
aujourd'hui si vous voulez si on veut
quantifier il ya eu à peu près et là
c'est à la fois des commerçants et des
artisans et à peu près plus de 1000
appels à ce niveau là et il ya eu 400
qui ont été vraiment pris en charge
merci beaucoup d'après les réponses
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions ou william koeberlé je
rappelle que vous êtes président du
conseil du commerce de france